hey what's going on as bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday May 8th 2017 what's going on
oh this is one of these days I don't
want to do the podcast you know
oh I'm putting on a [ __ ] brave face
right now I got the energy in my voice
right I'm trying to bring it for you do
you know what I'm really feeling inside
is what I really feel like a nice bill
birnes changing on Monday morning hi
kids
um just even doing that just brought my
energy down to the [ __ ] man I can't
I got a salad speaking of which he I was
just watching that Quiet Riot
documentary where it was like now you're
here now what the [ __ ] you going to do
whatever it's called and they would
after Kevin Dubrow died they got this
new guy you could really sound like him
and hit all the notes like the first
[ __ ] show he goes out there he's just
like you guys want to bang your hit the
drummer afterwards Frankie Banali was
giving him [ __ ] going dude you can't
just you gotta [ __ ] and sell it that's
what I love about watching those
documentaries it says so many those
bands especially with metal music in the
80s they just thought it was a bunch of
morons that we're just out there you
know just dumb people and then you
listen to them breaking down the show
and it's like yeah these guys completely
get performance they totally emigrant
why would yeah you right you would have
to do that to sell the amount of records
that they did but for some reason
because of the subject matter you don't
think that they you just think that
doing it and they're not thinking about
it put out he just got off we just
[ __ ] read the guy the riot act he's
now here we got like a 20-foot bike
20-foot stage and you're performing like
3 feet by 3 feet
you're nuts you gotta gather you got to
sell it you got to sell it I would have
loved to been at then show watching the
rest of the bed because they're all pros
knowing how to sell it and then there's
this one guy in the middle looking like
he's doing the [ __ ]
Riverdance you know with his hands down
by his side his fee to cut it jumping
around you know dancing on one [ __ ]
square piece of linoleum linoleum um
it's a great word isn't linoleum it's a
good name for a band isn't it some glam
band you just call it linoleum there you
go sing a couple of songs about pledge
you know with some other cleaner and
that's just your thing that's a wide
open lane nobody's ever done that I may
go on [ __ ] that hey that's my band
name dotnet and registered to seven
bucks whatever they charge I love how
you can just register [ __ ] online like
when I was was just going to some guy's
house why are you acting like this is
some good governmental building then a
word governmental federal ental how do
you say it the Federal Reserve is no
more federal than Federal Express so guy
tears up a 20
I never he dives on it [ __ ] tapes it
back together then goes buys themselves
a Sawbuck blimpy now when you got to
save yeah buddy we're gonna tell you
next the world is flat not that I don't
agree not that I don't agree with that
hypothetical person um anyways plowing
ahead here how are you how was your
Monday I was going to get up this
morning Bobby will do and get on the
elliptical and I did not I woke up this
morning and felt like I played three
years in the NFL and what I did last
week was I really researched what the
[ __ ] I was doing wrong with my leg
workout you know cuz you know I have
thighs of Steel's but buns of applesauce
on and I'm not talking about the [ __ ]
job and what I realized was that my
[ __ ] my whatever the [ __ ] my quads
were doing all the work right my ass was
just like some lazy dude just [ __ ]
going along for the ride you know like
that person when you're at the foretop
and the check comes at the end of the
night and everybody's digging in their
pockets and stuff and that person just
kind of [ __ ]
oh man yeah you're not going to believe
this I left my wallet at home
I'm dead right that's what my ass is
like it's like the [ __ ] dude who
doesn't throw in at the end of the
[ __ ] night you know he always come up
short you always come up short it's the
guy who collects the [ __ ] I still bit
about this the guy who collects the
money you know everybody throws in 20
bucks and somehow you always 10 bucks
short it's the guy who collects the
money he's the guy who [ __ ] he
shorted because once he collects the
money all he's going to say is how much
you have and what you need and he's just
gonna keep counting it you know and then
eventually one of you guys is just going
to [ __ ] cave out of being like you
know not liking confrontation and then
you're gonna throw in and then this
[ __ ] got his meal for $5 $6 $7 left
alright so anyways I got this new
workout that I've been doing and I did
that and then the other night you know
that I'd already worked out that day and
I went out in the garage sorta stretched
and then skipped rope for [ __ ] three
rounds and I woke up this morning oh my
god
I felt like you know I felt like I ran a
marathon sometimes I forget my age you
know [ __ ] cracks me up as people tell
me I'm an old dad it's like no I'm not
I'm not when you really look at when you
go around I mean as far as my my age yes
I am but but the physical shape I'm in
no because this is this is the in
defense of me you guys can argue this
I'm not saying I'm old to be a dad but
I'm not an old dad all right cuz it's
what happens if you have a kid at
[ __ ] 25 I see people that weird kid
at 25 I see what they look like at 35
all right
after finishing the kids food and doing
all of that she whatever the [ __ ] it is
they do you know their body's dead done
they've finished all right I'm still
doing pull-ups forty eight [ __ ] years
old I'll get on a bike you know I skip
rope I don't know maybe I need a new
pair of those [ __ ] Steve job New
Balance you know the classic old white
guy sneakers which are now those
Skechers
that is now the official my [ __ ] feet
hurt old white guy not even old white
guy cuz those dudes shacking all of them
wear it on is it TNT a TBS I was getting
confused whatever channel the
basketballs on you know whenever that
one dude gets up and he goes over to the
giant flat-screen TV and then wearing
like the suit and they got the [ __ ]
sneakers on you know this there's
nothing worse than the old guy [ __ ]
sneakers all right hang on a second I
got a [ __ ] hang on
all right I'm back what was going on
there son was like I was on a [ __ ]
airplane my nose was closing up um ah we
go what the hell I was talking about oh
it's how much sketches yeah that is the
official it's just it's it's [ __ ]
over you know what I mean like if I was
a gold-digging [ __ ] you know I go to
the steak houses you know with a [ __ ]
rich [ __ ] dudes hangout and that's
all I'd be looking for I look for that
[ __ ] guy in the sketches and I'd be
like alright this guy's got no fight
left in him you know you do is bat your
eyes at him and then that's it oh my god
you [ __ ] hobbles over you're like wow
those are really interesting shoes oh
she's get all excited about him it's
like a walking on a cloud yeah once you
walk on a cloud over to your [ __ ] atm
I'm telling you right now this carrot if
you're a [ __ ] old rich dude right now
do not get a pair of sketches all right
you might as well have a please gold dig
me sign on the back of your [ __ ]
sport coat you know um anyway speaking
of that I'm [ __ ] worried about I'm
not going to say the guy's name there's
a [ __ ] guy watching sports he's
[ __ ] huge now it's [ __ ] huge just
can't be that big can't be that big he
stuck etting in those [ __ ] those ages
you know you retire a couple years you
just blow up it's not going to be good
you know it's watching that quiet right
thing as I mentioned and you know they
always made it seem like [ __ ] the
lead singer Kevin Dubrow like died under
like a mountain of coke
and it really wasn't he had a little bit
of cocaine a little bit of Valium a
little bit of alcohol and the [ __ ]
you know the Quincy guy there
the Jack Klugman Quincy guy was sitting
there saying that once you get past a
certain age he goes you can't do that
you just can't do that today hey man
we're [ __ ] ramping it up now we're
slowing it down and we're gonna level it
out you Bart's just like you know what
[ __ ] this how about that I'm calling the
shots now not you that's how it goes
down you know so anyways getting back to
that thing
all these [ __ ] I'm telling you you
look at any dad ten years in Delhi 90%
of them she can throw that out there
without any research like 30 pounds over
[ __ ] weight
alright I have lost weight since I've
had a kid yeah I'm not gonna be the fat
dad I'm not I'm not going out like that
I'm just not not saying you know at some
point you know gravity takes over you
know I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm a Justin I'm not fighting nature I
mean I'm trying to stay in [ __ ] shape
but you know I just whatever you know
some of my hair started leaving I was
like you know what [ __ ] all you I'm out
just shaved it done what now what next
you can't go here plugs bad you can't
[ __ ] into it it's a slippery slope you
know you start doing that Michael
Jackson [ __ ] did he like Oh what if I
had a booty chin huh would that make me
feel good about myself and you get the
Botox then you get the [ __ ] do they
have do they have like fake like man
pecs yet you know and you can walk in
and pick like the chest you want like
off-the-wall chesticles whatever the
[ __ ] they call pecs
you know um I'm looking look for like a
Ben Hur meets a Ken Patera I don't know
what you would do
I bet that's what it's gonna be like in
the future everybody's gonna be like
you're going to be like a restomod right
where it's going to be like I'm going to
be a 1968
white male heterosexual right but under
the hood I'm gonna have like a [ __ ]
you know there's the [ __ ] zo6
20 that will be your heart right you get
a brand new [ __ ] heart
brand new [ __ ] hot that's like some
sci-fi [ __ ] you know where it's like oh
god this is so [ __ ] up you'd have two
kids one kid would be your real kid the
other came to be like the donor for the
family bill why why would you do that no
cuz you couldn't do that that's what
rich people would do rich people okay
once they have like all the robots
around there man chess is a [ __ ]
movie right here they get all the rope
robots garden them right and the only
reason why they keep [ __ ] people
alive is that they need to like harvest
their parts but they don't want the
[ __ ] poor people to completely rebel
and take out a couple of their robots
because they're probably the same amount
of money it's like a [ __ ] f-18 right
so what they'll do is they'll say all
right poor people you're allowed to have
like you know four kids
and for every four kids you have like
you know two of them got to be donors or
something like that you don't I mean so
like when I get to the age um you know I
got to start wearing Skechers you know
you come in you [ __ ] take the feet
you know ah God bill that's so [ __ ]
dark I know it is I know it is I've just
been in a really dark place I don't know
some about becoming a parent you just
start thinking about them the most
horrific [ __ ] [ __ ] that could
possibly happen you know I swear to God
[ __ ] that used to kind of bug me now
like really bugs me you know if I see
anything on TV if somebody like abusing
a kid obviously that always bugs you but
once you [ __ ] have one you're just
like you just start thinking like man
they should just people who do that
should they should be lit on fire then
right before they die you put them out
I don't know what you would call that
punishment what do you call that uh what
do they call that when you're [ __ ]
when you cook a [ __ ] steak sear it
yeah we're going to sear you that's what
we're going to do you sear it keep all
the [ __ ] vitals to get out or no pill
Jesus Christ you know what we listen to
this podcast bill to get away from our
troubles all right
fair enough [ __ ] fair enough
I had a fun day yesterday when I wasn't
watching the Celtics just get the [ __ ]
kicked out of them in the second half
you know but I know we're gonna win Game
six I don't even know that I hope we're
gonna win Game six you know I know
people learn not to talk [ __ ] because it
just motivates the other [ __ ] team
and then fans don't get that either I
didn't see it you know those busy this
weekend had family in town visiting my
daughter and I guess someone on the
Celtics I know if it was Green said yeah
we're definitely gonna beat him in the
next game it said why would you do that
that thing that [ __ ] wall did on
Instagram alone to that guy in the
Atlanta Hawks you know this guy [ __ ]
thrives off a grudge why the [ __ ] would
you do that so that the Wizard fans come
on I think they just saw the results of
[ __ ] talk right and I'm watching the
Celtics walk off the court after a loss
and you see two [ __ ] goddamn you know
cotton candy eating fatties not even fat
but just dad bods just clap and go net
great job great job like yelling at the
Celtics is that going up the court it's
like he [ __ ] [ __ ] why would you do
that you don't say anything you cheer
politely you let them walk by and then
that's it and you let doubt slip into
their [ __ ] head you don't [ __ ]
yell at a professional athlete you think
they're going to implode this isn't a
field goal kicker
somebody's got the balls to go down the
[ __ ] lane right
all that's gonna do is motivate him you
guys never learn that [ __ ] [ __ ]
morons and I'm talking to Celtics fans
too because they also do it you know I
hate those people like right after they
win a game they just got to [ __ ] talk
all this [ __ ] you know
Celtics get that ass slapped all that
[ __ ] it's like dude it's 2-2 and then
they're going to disappear into the
abyss if we win another two that [ __ ]
happens every time so we'll see I want
to say that the Celtics will win the
next game and then I think we lose in
Washington and then it just becomes like
what team is going to win on the road or
is the home team gonna hold served the
better than it did it did it did it what
am i [ __ ] doing the NBA thank you I
got to be honest with you as much as I
really come back to the NBA and I
enjoyed it
I when I'm watching an NBA game when
there's an NHL game and I flip over to
it it's not even close to the level of
[ __ ] excitement it's people jogging
up the court versus people like skating
around doing like 20 30 miles an hour
slamming into each other basketball
people they're all about over there's no
scoring which I understand it's one of
my big complaints about when you watch
soccer other than the [ __ ] flopping
which by the way Jesus Christ did you
guys see what's his face doing his
salmon up the river
that guy's named Bill or whatever on DC
and you just see all the [ __ ] memes
about that guy that was one of the worst
see if he just dove that would have been
fine but the way he threw his head back
good lord [ __ ] Quiet Riot I to have
him as a front man he'd [ __ ] sell
every goddamn song died without a doubt
but I got a mitt I you know hockey's
just where what's that and I got I
almost have to apologize the Ottawa
Senators I was watching that [ __ ]
game the other day and uh was it the
Rangers was that what was the score were
they up for two three so what it was
scored the fourth goal with like seven
minutes to go and I'm rooting for the
Rangers wife I hate New York sports fans
you know can't stand them but oughta
what be my Bruin so I'm like [ __ ] and
I always got like a soft spot spot for
the ranges because I rooted for them in
94 to win the Cup and that's one of the
greats
you know runs I ever saw in sports so
I'm rooting for him right plus I got a
couple of friends at a big range of fans
so it's four to three gets down like a
minute change left and I'm thinking oh
and I got family coming over right I got
to go downstairs I got to fire up the
flattop gonna make some burgers a little
bit of hash browns I don't do french
fries I go hash browns I go hash browns
on a flat top grill
I don't like french fries french fries
past a certain [ __ ] age you can't do
it they just take it down to the mat
it's not the burgers it's the fries it's
not the pizza it's the soda or maybe
it's the combination of the two that's
probably what it really is we have both
of them it's just like it's [ __ ] over
right so I feel like I'm fine I go
downstairs you know be brothers over
here a couple of bud Hyde's
right I come back in the [ __ ] house
and he's like he's like Ottawa one going
me the [ __ ] one what how do they win
tied it up with like no time left like
then they gave me all right there Fred
and overtime
anyways my apologies to the Ottawa
Senators I just did not believe in them
evidently they're for real and I think
they're going to take this series see
what I just did there it made it sound
like I was saying something positive
about Ottawa but any real sports fans
knows what I'm doing right now I'm
trying to put a hex on the old Ronnie
Hextall now I'm [ __ ] with you I keep
forgetting the Rangers were like a wild
card I don't know the [ __ ] Anderson
dude that guys these he's the guy
everybody keeps talking about the dude
with the busted foot skating around
there Carlson whatever the hell his name
is I can't you know once once the
Russians came in and all the east and
the Finnish people I haven't been able
to remember anybody's [ __ ] name
really bill you're gonna blame that or
your lack of short-term memory all right
maybe you got me maybe that's what it is
all right let me type in my password
here and let's see let's see
see we got coming up here I got to read
a little bit of advertising here I'm in
19 minutes and I will we will talk about
who the [ __ ] is Bonamassa live on
tour near you get tickets now these
shows will sell out this [ __ ]
guitarist this flyer has been on
everything I've looked at I don't know
what I clicked on I don't know what I
clicked on well here's the article I
clicked on to engaged doctors found
bound in slain in luxury Boston
penthouse suspect in custody after
shootout who the [ __ ] is Ed she said
it's somebody's 39th birthday tomorrow
and have no idea what it is
he's [ __ ] computers man I don't I
don't know I don't know what's going on
with them um all right
so to talk to doctors who are engaged
one was 49 right the other was 39 right
or 38 Boston police entered the 11th
floor penthouse apartment Friday night
they found a gruesome scene which I'm
not going to talk about luxury condo and
this is what kills me about this whole
story no pun intended
levan floor luxury penthouse in
Dorchester you know I know I moved away
in 1995 I know that's 22 years ago but
the fact that there's a luxury penthouse
that two doctors are living in in
Dorchester isn't unbelievable I mean
when I was a kid they used to talk about
what Dorchester used to be they used to
say oh this used to be this upscale
place and blah blah blah
then it became blue-collar and then the
[ __ ] crack eighties can't and an old
[ __ ] that goes to [ __ ] right to think
that it's now back this is what I don't
understand it's like every neighborhood
now has become in high-end it's like
where where is everybody else going to
go I really hope we don't end up like a
third-world country where it's just like
you know if you have a bender one it's
like you'll see like these ridiculous
mansions and you know in a gated
community with people like with like
[ __ ] machine guns standing outside of
them and then everybody else is living
in a [ __ ] tin shack
I don't know is that what I was supposed
to get out of that story I mean
obviously my condolence goes out to
those two people and they caught the
[ __ ] douchebag who did it
lunatic Trump's war on science continues
with EPA firings president Trump's war
on basic facts continues but this time
you literally end up choking on it
Jesus crazy what is it about why do
Republicans just act like the earth is
just you know like it's not a finite
thing I just don't understand I get that
you have companies I get to you sick of
the tree huggers going hey man you're
putting too many greenhouse gases I
understand that that becomes annoying to
you because all you stare at is your
[ __ ] bottom line but like I just
don't understand those [ __ ] people
they just sit there's plenty of water
look at the lake over there like how
they just look at it like that just
don't understand it I think that it's
just so [ __ ] psycho competitive or
just so unbelievably selfish were like
well even if what the tree huggers are
saying is true it's not going to happen
in my lifetime and even it does I'll be
too old to give a [ __ ]
Facebook's war against fake news in the
UK is long overdue
what is Facebook conservative you know
that I don't like that guy I don't like
that [ __ ] guy Zuckerberg whatever his
[ __ ] name is that runs this thing
since since what why is he so [ __ ]
involved in fake news you have a site
that's for people to like you know
figure out who the [ __ ] they're gonna
bang that they used to went to high
school with in November Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg said the idea that
so-called fake news could influence the
US election was quote crazy dude can you
guys read between the lines here it's
all [ __ ] fake news it's all spun this
guy you know what this guy is right now
this guy's like he's a made guy and now
he has a dog in the fight
this [ __ ] dope now he's on dope
obviously started this [ __ ] this
little [ __ ] chitchat site now he's
going to decide what is real and what is
fake so maybe he said it was crazy that
it couldn't have influenced it bill
maybe should read the whole article
before you throw this billionaire under
the bus okay fair enough
sorry mark six months later however the
social network has announced an all-out
war on misinformation and hoaxes in the
UK before the general election in June
oh I see I see you know what he either
got paid off or he got a phone call
about a convertible ride in Dallas
that's what somebody just called up you
know he just picks it up picks up the
phone hello Facebook right and then he
just had that you know that voice they
always have you know whenever they have
like the gang members on TV like your
old fresno mofo gonna grab a beer prayer
right
they had like that voice except it was
like Illuminati hitman calling up you
know he's like hazy mark Facebook how
may I help you
mark if you don't get were left
recruiting over there we're gonna stick
on apple new airs something like that
they scared the [ __ ] out of them you
know what you know you scare the [ __ ]
out of a [ __ ] nerd you just take his
phone away you take his phone away and
then you've threatened to burn one of
his superhero costumes and that
[ __ ] will tell you anything you
want so now he's having this all-out war
on fake news how do what the [ __ ] is why
um how do you tell what is faking what
is everybody's lying everybody's a
[ __ ] liar how many lies do you think
Hillary and Trump told combined in just
one debate you got two piles of [ __ ]
just say the other one smells worse
right isn't that what it is everybody's
lying oh [ __ ] think you know I still
don't understand I know I always say
this whenever a bill gets passed why did
they always have to
are they allowed to tag on all these
other [ __ ] things I've never
understood anyway six months later the
guys fees an all-out war on
misinformation and hoaxes in the UK
that's because they voted to leave the
European Union which probably [ __ ]
with the bankers who want to have
everybody all unified all on one
currency that they are [ __ ] printing
so inadvertently people just say an amen
let's get the [ __ ] out here and now you
got to have an all-out war on it that's
what happened
the bankers hitmen call this guy up
right all right Facebook is tweaking its
algorithms to try to halt the spread of
misinformation giving users tips on
identifying sources designed to miss
inform and it even ran full-page
advertisements in British newspapers on
Monday reiterating how to spot
misinformation online I want to want to
say you can see the full advertising
Times meant below let's see what they
got here all right tips for spotting
false news one the person you're talking
to is wearing a trench coat with the
fedora and sunglasses all right be
skeptical of headlines you know what
they just took a picture of the
newspaper so I can't see this here look
closely at the URL investigate the
source watch for unusual formatting
consider the photos inspect the dates
check the evidence look at other reports
is the story a joke some stories are
intentionally false I don't know if you
use this algorithm for Facebook would
Facebook still exist I mean the whole
[ __ ] thing is fake everybody picks
takes a picture they hold the camera up
over their [ __ ] face so that drops
like 40 pounds and upstair number from a
four to A six is six to an eight right
everybody photoshop's and does all that
[ __ ] was it wasn't old kung fu Kenny
talking about that in his song I don't
[ __ ] it why do I clean some of Wall
Street's top booty
firms just landed a big payday for some
reason they have a picture of Aziz
Ansari I mean isn't that misinformation
right there seasoned sorry he's not one
of Wall Street's top boutique firms is
he
that's misinformation he's a stand-up
comedian as far as I know um all right I
think I think I [ __ ] filibustered long
enough Avenue you know it's funny when I
think of Mark Zuckerberg I don't think
of Mark Zuckerberg I think of the
[ __ ] guy that played him in the movie
and you know when I look at Mark
Zuckerberg he looks way more annoying um
okay
oh Jesus Mother's Day is coming up you
know so you know what you gotta get her
you gotta get answer Sherry's berries
talk about your favorite story about
your mom I talk about a television mom
you really admire and why you know what
I always wanted to bang Alice on that
show Alice there was something about it
you know what I mean she was like 39 40
so you know what she was doing in the
rack you know she had that Charlie's
Angels haircut she could sing a little
bit you know she's busy she's got a
couple of kids she's not gonna [ __ ]
around she's gonna look at you like you
want to do this so what how do you want
to do it I'd be like keep the uniform on
all right
Mother's Day is coming up and Sherry's
berries is offering huge freshly dipped
strawberries starting at $19.99 plus
shipping and right now I have an
exclusive offer you that is only
available on this podcast and the other
15,000 they advertise on when you double
the berries
oh Jesus mom's getting a threesome here
for mom for just $10 more she will get
free cake truffles free cake truffles
too that's not like a whole extra gift
for free pick your delivery date and
Sherry's berries guarantees your gifts
will arrive fresh and delicious or your
money back that's not like two gifts if
you
if you get Sherry's berry and then cake
truffles that's like you took your girl
out for pizza and you got the old
mozzarella sticks and then what are you
gonna say I took you out for two meals
no you didn't you got me a [ __ ]
appetizer in a couple of slices then you
manhandled me in you Chevy Vega all
right pick up your delivery date at
Sherry's berries pick your delivery date
sorry and Sherry's berries guarantees
your gifts will arrive fresh and
delicious or your money back
please use this time to tell you
listeners about to Cherie about what
you're Sherry's berries look like tasted
like and your overall impression of them
chocolate-covered strawberries grossed
me up I don't know what it is there's
something about them because they're
always used in like a sexual kind of way
that was like a cheesy thing when I grew
up to have like chocolate-covered
strawberries then he had like a
heart-shaped [ __ ] bed that vibrated
which I also never understood you know
what I mean like who would want to bang
while driving over a gravel road at 40
miles an hour
evidently people in the 70s you know it
was as they didn't trim their pubes so
they had enough of a cushion um anyways
you may think you've seen gourmet dip
strawberries before I never said that
but you have never seen anything like
these Sherry's berries are huge sweet
juicy and covered in decadent toppings
chocolate chips chocolate nuts white
milk Caucasian dark chocolate Puerto
Rican goodness Sherry's berries are an
unexpected gift that will put a smile on
my mom's face my mom's to see I read
this way I filmed dyslexics because I
saw the Y in any and then I saw the M
and mom and then that board becomes mom
I see I wasn't dumb all those years cool
surprise the mom in your life that's
pretty vague with Sherry's berries at
her office slash workplace reminds me
that great kids book are you my mother
the only way to get amazing berries
deals starting at just not
a [ __ ] bird imagine how many
strawberries that thing attaboy
at just $19.99 you visit berries calm
click on the microphone at the top right
hand corner and use my code Burpee URR
that's berries calm ber RI es can code
bird you know what they should use Chuck
Berry to do this now he's passed away
when you click on the mic the amazing
deal won't last long and Mother's Day is
right around the corner it's this Sunday
everybody and so be sure to order now oh
and after you get to the
chocolate-covered strawberries get us
some flowers to apologize for the fact
that our hips are going to expand
proflowers.com everybody talk about what
things you still go to your mom /a
mother figure for advice on dude I'm
[ __ ] 48 I cut the cord a long time
ago I just call my mom up to tell her I
love her when you send a hundred blooms
for your mom bouquet or bouquet from Pro
flowers this Mother's Day you will make
a real impression you know what I do
every once in a while for making a
family recipe I'll call her up and be
like mom I can't read you right in here
and what is that it comes with a free
glass vase for just $19.99 plus shipping
and handling and if you really want to
make a statement you can upgrade to a
premium vase and include gourmet
chocolates for just $10 more choose the
delivery date you want and ProFlowers
are guaranteed to arrive fresh and
beautiful and stay that way for at least
7 days or your money back
please use this time to tell your
listeners about what ProFlowers bouquet
bouquet look like and your overall
impression of it well I don't have one
so I don't know I imagine it looks
imagine it it's it's an explosion of
color you know leaving its host to the
vase right reaching up to the Sun
wondering why its feet got cut off
mothers love fresh flowers and pro
flowers make it easy to send the perfect
Mother's Day gift with this huge bouquet
don't forget all the moms in your life
mom grandma wife and other mother
figures this Mother's Day Jesus Christ
can these [ __ ] make and
money any woman walking down the street
a lady you a mom well you will be is
some flowers the only way to get 100
blooms from mom with a free glass vase
starting at $19.99 is to visit
ProFlowers click on the microphone in
the top right hand corner and use my
code burr that's plov proflowers.com
[Music]
burr those / / when you click on the mic
oh use my code bro ok I see you go to
proflowers.com and you click on the mic
the any type at burr okay the stunning
bouquet sells out fast so order today
all right up side sorry I [ __ ] up the
end of that I mean I will tell you why I
[ __ ] up the end of that because I'm
going to see my mother for this Mother's
Day and I'm actually going to go to this
[ __ ] chocolate place down the street
to get mud up side there's a better way
for you to buy business travel
it's called upside calm every time you
buy trip an upside you'll save your
company a ton of money you know I don't
feel like reading this [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's three more of them I don't want
to do this I don't want to talk about
this lets us [ __ ] let me just give my
brain a break alright so anyways
yesterday I did this thing was the
Ronnie James Dio ride for cancer which I
it should be a ride to fight cancer it
said was the ride for cancer I was like
these people for cancer these people
fans of disco and then I showed up and
was a bunch of people [ __ ] Harley
Davidsons and you know knives on their
hips and [ __ ] I was like no these guys
are fighting cancer ok I get it
so I show up at this thing was in Encino
outside of this park and I come walking
in and I'm going to introduce Steven
Adler's all-star band that he's putting
together right and they're going to play
a few songs any money was there he was
[ __ ] hilarious [ __ ] hilarious
everybody they're like I don't know
everybody that was just [ __ ] killing
it and had like a sense of humor about
you know can throw outside it started
raining a little bit and so I walk in
there going like alright so they want me
to joke around a little bit in intro the
and and it's outside the sun's out and
then it starts [ __ ] raining it's a
bunch of bikers this one guy walked
tonight so sweaty got on his the back of
his belt he had this [ __ ] sheath
knife it was like a [ __ ] ten inch
blade it's like what are you gonna do
with that you know the [ __ ] are you
gonna do with that thing that's not to
defend yourself you're gonna murder
anybody that's what it is people see
that and it's just dude this guy could
kill a [ __ ] bear with this thing so
I'm just thinking oh god this is how is
this gonna go right so I'm watching the
bands and I'm enjoying everybody yet in
the back of my head going like well how
the [ __ ] I'm going to deal with this
Eddie trunk was there and he was intro
in the band and they were being nice and
polite to him so I was thinking all
right but he's not trying to be funny
even though he was being funny but he
wasn't billed as a stand-up comedian so
I ended up going up there joked around a
little bit they laughed and I intro the
band I turned around then of course they
give me the stretch sign you know
because it had finally stopped [ __ ]
raining they were getting rid of the
full posted canopy that they had over
the drum kit and I actually joked around
I went good I had a great [ __ ] time
and it took me back to when I used to do
college gigs the college gigs whether
were the worst because she'd show up as
an unknown comedian and they would
[ __ ] stick you anywhere outside
inside raining snowing they didn't give
a [ __ ]
cafeteria hallway Mike no Mike L figured
come up walk out of that walk-in closet
it just took me back to those days and
like really having to fight to get the
crowd and I ended up having a great time
and it was great man I got to watch
[ __ ] Adler play again and he always
killing me was he does a lot of those
[ __ ] three in the row in them on the
bass drum
you know just playing even like eighth
notes at like a mid-tempo and but the
way he puts him in really propels the
song so I'm watching to play welcome to
the jungle and the last time I watched a
play I figured out some
he was doing so this time I'm watching
his footwork all right and this [ __ ]
guy taking picture of him every time he
goes to do that thing like and I'm
starting to get it this guy keeps
getting in my way and then like I had
this then the cameraman finally got out
of the way and I'm getting to watch and
play a whole verse and it's coming I
have this anxiety going please please
don't anybody [ __ ] this up don't anybody
[ __ ] this up and I'm sunny feel this tap
on the shoulder hey Bill big fan boy yes
I get a picture as I I have too much of
a need to be like to say hang on a
second so I [ __ ] missed it again
because my ears aren't good enough the
way they've mixed it you know what I
mean but the bass and the bass drum
sometimes I can't tell he didn't do you
know I was what's he playing right there
I don't know I don't know it's a will be
a lifelong [ __ ] obsession but I got
to watch them do that Lita Ford came out
saying sweet child of mine and then they
played rocket queen he [ __ ] murdered
it and and I had a great time so thank
you to everybody at that event who
showed up to raise money for cancer you
know was the best was at one point they
were singing a do song and let's tell my
buddy about this and first of all I'm
looking at all the people in the [ __ ]
crowd and they're all my age and a
little bit older and I'm just like wow
man we are [ __ ] old right but
everybody's having a great time and this
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude five foot nothing
goes up there I saw him on another event
and he somehow related to Ronnie Oh
doesn't I don't know if he's in a person
I don't know what but he Kihei really
captures like Ronnie's range and really
can sound like him and he started
singing dude the crowd it was just one
[ __ ] guy in the crowd man he [ __ ]
lost it he still had the Vince Neil
haircut not the teased up one when it's
just [ __ ] laid down he had like a
[ __ ] keg cup filled with beer well
into his 50s you know so he's got the
whole dad bought it [ __ ] he lost his
[ __ ] mind because I knew this guy was
good so I was looking in the crowd
because I want to see their reaction and
this guy just
[ __ ] lost it he's just pointing it he
started pointing at the singer like you
know doing a double point while holding
this copy was just like looking at his
friend his eyes are all wide couldn't
[ __ ] believe it and I was thinking
like that was a kid when I would go to
go see these bands who was above five
years older than me
you know already had like the [ __ ]
awful mustache going and you know you
need to have some hot skanky looking
chick with some [ __ ] pink and black
you know leopard print spandex on you
know and I was sitting there with my
[ __ ] you know
Ralph's mouth look you know couldn't
grow my hair would never grow down and
would just grow out look like [ __ ]
Bernie from room 222
and I just always always think like duh
man fight brown flat hair band I could
get one of those spandex chicks he's to
think that [ __ ] rather than thinking
like why don't you just [ __ ] have a
little confidence to say hello you know
this is the one thing no matter how
[ __ ] up you look you have to hold on
to the fact that you got to be
somebody's fetish there's always hope
you know what I mean you're not ugly you
just haven't met somebody who's into
what you're doing or the [ __ ] hand
you were dealt okay
and if anything tells me that it's when
you watch those storage wars because to
me that's just a bunch of [ __ ] I don't
want any of it and everybody's [ __ ]
everybody else is freaking out like dude
look at that that's a dartboard I think
that's a dartboard in that case my god
that's a refrigerator you think there's
food in there you don't the [ __ ] that
they're looking at you know maybe that's
what you are maybe physically what you
look like you're the human version of
what they find in those storage sheds
you know and if you got a great heart
well goddamn it you're like one of those
original Civil War [ __ ] muskets all
right that was positive that was a
positive thing so I think it's time you
know what I think I can do a little more
advertising there okay up side everybody
second attempt coming around again you
might have heard this earlier in the
podcast evidently there's a better way
for you to buy business travel it's
called upside comm every time you buy a
goddamn trip an upside you'll save your
company a ton of money
and they give you a gift card an amazon
gift card worth hundreds of dollars that
doesn't make any sense I mean a [ __ ]
plane tickets about 300 bucks and you
gonna give me $200 worth of DVDs how are
you making any money upsides able to do
this because they bundle your flights
and hotels together for one low price
bundled pricing saves money if you're a
frequent business traveler your company
saves a ton of money and you could get
thousands a year in gift cards just by
buying your air and hotel together
upside plus you'll still get all your
miles if you're shopping for business
travel you'd be crazy not to check out
upside comm it just takes three minutes
to see how much you've saved by buying
your flights and hotel together for one
low price
I can't even reckoning and see the words
anymore I don't know what happened
my eyes are fatigued there right now
when you use my name Burpee you are are
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100
Amazon gift card your first trip that's
my name burr to get at least a $100
Amazon gift card for free say big on
travel and get big gift card every time
evidently I love upside calm upside calm
minimum purchase required see site for
complete details all right two more two
more jesus [ __ ] christ bell here we
go Dollar Shave Club Joe you got here on
your face you want to get rid of it you
don't want to spend a zillion dollar
what Dollar Shave Club is the smart
choice you'll get a great shave at a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your goddamn door you no longer have
to schlep to the [ __ ] store buy it
cheap disposable razors that gave you a
cheap shave or spent a fortune on raises
with gimmicky shaving technique
technology you didn't even need and when
you use Dollar Shave club's executive
razor with their easy-to-use doctor
copies easy
shei blade gently glides giving you a
smooth shave
dr. cabbies shave butter dr. Carver's
shave butter is transparent for a more
precise shave helps prevent ingrown
hairs and fights razor bumps make the
smart choice by going to Dollar Shave
Club for a limited time new members get
their first month the executive razor
with a tube of their doctor copies shea
butter for only five dollars with free
shipping and that after that razors are
just a few bucks a month that's a 15
dollar value for only five dollars one
more paragraph there are no hidden fees
and no commitments cancelling time you
like you can only get this exclusive
offer at dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / i'll thank
christ one more this is like last period
back when I was in school just staring
at the clock you know then you find out
you got a substitute teacher oh thank
God thank God I don't have to think for
the next 42 [ __ ] minutes stamps.com
everybody I use stamps.com anytime I'm
whoring myself out selling merchandise
at the end of my shows I'm a [ __ ] if I
can figure out how to do it so can you
stamp save you time and money which you
can use to grow your business I can mail
any letter any package just using my
computer and printer and the mailman
picks it up avoid the hassle of the post
office and mail everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamp stamps accountant minutes online
with no equipment to lease and no
long-term commitments click print mail
show cheque and you're done unlike the
post office stamps calm never closes
print postage for letters and packages
at your convenience 24/7 seven days a
week
hi doing bench keywords / descriptors
convenient easy reliable flexible I
don't know what that means
right now you can enjoy the Stamp
service with a special offer that
includes a full week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps calm click on
the microphone to the top of the
homepage and type in / that stamps calm
enter / stamps calm never go to the post
office again hey you guys know al
Madrigal one of the cofounders of the
all things comedy Network huh now that
we're making [ __ ] video content we got
a cooking show coming up we got a
political show coming out we got this
poker game we shot we got we got [ __ ] we
got investors it's all going great well
listen al Madrigal has a new [ __ ]
special that is uh right now it's it
premiered last Friday night on Showtime
and it is now on Showtime on demand and
speaking of all things comedy there's a
new podcast out from the the wonderful
Nick Youssef it's called Nick America
Nick interviews people from all
backgrounds about what makes them
American this week he has comedian Fahim
Anwar subscribe and listen on iTunes or
SoundCloud on the all things comedy page
all right let's let's get into uh let's
read some [ __ ] here for the week all
right let's some questions here 95 year
old hockey player hey Billy puck nuts I
saw this video and thought you'd get a
kick out of it maybe it'll even motivate
you to get your old red tits out there
and keep playing hockey I want to I just
don't have time
it's amazing how how much good you can
do to yourself just by staying active
anyways here's the link and go [ __ ]
yourself PS thanks for making my
workdays crawl by a little bit faster
there dude it means a lot kids um
anyways yeah I watch this guy's 95 years
old he's still playing pick-up hockey
obviously he's not flying around out
there but uh that's another reason why
hockey's great it's one of the greatest
old men's sports ever because you don't
have to run around you just gliding you
know it's great cardio it's phenomenal
man in the spirit of that guy I got to
get back out there playing I have not
played since I played in like September
or October of 2015
I didn't play once last year and I've
yet to play this year it's hard because
we get ice time late at night and you
know I got the kid now who by the way
I'm telling you late at night is in the
morning and late at night my two
favorite times you know when she just
wakes up and she
just looking at in she's just talking
all this gibberish smiling and all that
and the late at night when she gets all
fussy and everything when me and Nia
just sit there and totally like engage
with her you know she's just like the
look on her face just completely
enamored you know you don't understand I
mean I obviously just heard Mireille
read out loud so you know how [ __ ]
dumb I am so to have another human being
looking at you like you have all the
answers I mean it's [ __ ] unbelievable
and then this fear creeps and we just
like what's going to happen the day she
realizes I really don't have any answers
honey let me introduce you to the world
of going with your gut alright fear of
driving
hello Billie boy I hope the day is
treating you and your family well well
thank you
well just like the title says I am
completely terrified to drive a car by
the way that guy just went totally
different rather than calling me an
[ __ ] he actually said something nice
I'm completely terrified of driving a
car I'm 21 and can't drive worth a [ __ ]
and I've been lucky enough to have a
family that takes me to my college for
classes which is thanked thankfully is
close by are they helping you or
enabling you the problem is I need my
license it's the last thing I need to
truly be independent the problem is that
when I get behind the wheel to practice
driving I tense up every horrible
outcome pours into my stupid brain what
if I make a mistake and get someone
killed or accidentally hit a car full of
kids and kill and kill them I would not
be able to live with myself so my brain
just goes into hyper mode and I just
start getting jittery and really
sweating I don't want to lose I don't
want to be this loser anymore bill any
advice yes drive on Sundays alright
drive to an empty parking lot it's hard
to find them nowadays because nobody
really you know gives a [ __ ] about those
old Puritan laws back in the day you
know with liquor stores that you could
everybody Sunday was a day arrest so I
learned how to drive my dad used to take
me down to the South Shore Plaza and
Braintree Massachusetts on Sundays and I
learned how to drive on like a 78 Chevy
svet 4-speed standard transmission I
actually took my driver's test on a
stick shift and they used to you know he
stood there with all of us he take us
down there you know he got to a certain
age he just take it down there he teach
you how to drive and that was the way to
do it so what I would do if I was you is
I would go down there have your parents
drive you down there and just drive
around an empty parking lot or drive
down like a quiet neighborhood and you
just gradually build more and more
confidence and the only way you get over
something is you got to face it so this
is what I would do right I would just go
down there you know first time you just
drive around there in the car the whole
time all right the next time you do it
you drive around and when you got 10
minutes left in the driving thing you
just tell you dad ed why don't you just
step out for a second I'll just same
thing I did last week when I got back
into flying the helicopter you know I
took two lessons one I wrote you know I
was with the instructor the next time
once again I was with the instructor and
then at the end of the lesson I asked
him to step out and I flew it around by
myself gives you confidence yeah my
palms were sweating I was nervous but
you know I mean that it's really a
metaphor in life dude I mean you kind of
got to face this type of [ __ ] so if I
was you considering you have such a fear
no pun intended
I would totally steer into this you
could take a defensive driving course
and then I bet there's actually I don't
know where you live but sometimes you
know they have like these uh I know out
here they have like they have a course
out here where they'll teach you how to
do all like that [ __ ] from the movies
like spin the car around I mean why
don't you go from being totally
terrified to just become a [ __ ]
expert you know learn how to do burnouts
and all of that [ __ ] then you become an
absolute terror on the [ __ ] Road
learn how to drift
you know just master the [ __ ] as much as
you can and then driving down the street
will be a joke and as far as like
killing a bunch of kids and everything
like that the level of Technology
nowadays with like the airbags and all
that you don't sound like you're gonna
be driving super fast so the worst thing
going to do is just crumple up some
fenders that's all but you could do it
you just get out there so just baby
steps baby steps that's all you got to
do I'm flying again this week I'm flying
on Tuesday and then I got some other
family coming in I'm going to take some
people up this weekend going up with
instructor I've yet to have the balls to
bring a passenger up even though I know
I could do it I can't take a family
member up
I was joking with the buddy my j-law hit
I think I'm going to take him up first I
was like dude I have to deal with the
pressure of just the love I have for a
friend
forget about an actual family member of
my wife or something like that so
anyways alright so that's what I would
do so do it is I get over my fear of you
know bringing up a passenger you know
you you update me I'll update you
alright so good luck you could do it man
all right ex-girlfriends blanket hey
Billy boo radley I have a question for
you my ex-girlfriends grandmother made
me a blanket for Christmas and I kept it
after we broke up we broke up a little
over six years ago my current girlfriend
and I have been together ever since we
just had our six year anniversary and
are talking about getting married my ex
just got married last week and brought
up the question of the blanket
wait a minute you broke up with this
woman six years ago you still love the
blanket she just got married it's six
years later and she just brought up the
question meaning you're still in contact
with her should we get rid of the
blanket I don't think you meant to say
your ex I think we don't even between
your current one
you just lost my ex-girlfriends
grandmother maybe blanket for Christmas
and I kept it after we broke up broke up
a little over six years ago my current
girlfriend and I have been together ever
since we just had a six-year anniversary
we're talking about getting married my
ex just got married last week
oh and that brought up the question of
the blanket I'm sorry
Jesus poor bastards probably listen to
this podcast scorned I said that I said
that in the sentence read white wrong
all right should we get rid of the
blanket it wouldn't it wouldn't that big
it wouldn't be that big a deal but my ex
grandmother stitch our names in our
anniversary into it oh my god dude what
the [ __ ] it's like a championship banner
for your former relationship also my
current girlfriend I really like the
blanket it's the color of the college
where my current girlfriend and I first
met and we have a lot of memories having
Minnesota blizzards under the blanket
dude this is so [ __ ] weird your new
girlfriend snuggled under a blanket with
your name and your past girlfriend's
name it was your anniversary date on it
my current girlfriends from California
and these were some of the first
blizzard she had seen so it was a
special experience for her what should
we do with the blanket I think you
should keep it you're [ __ ] weirdos I
don't any advice for this is the
weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever so my
ex-girlfriend just got married last
weekend that brought up the question of
the blanket from who you both seem to
like it
Jesus Christ why do you make a voodoo
doll of your [ __ ] ex-girlfriend and
spoon with it between the two and have a
threesome we would appreciate your
advice as we are both fans of the
podcast and you stand up thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah you guys are [ __ ]
bizarre when it comes to that Jesus
Christ why don't you just put in a
[ __ ] sex tape you guys made oh I
don't maybe I read it wrong
maybe I was being too harsh I apologized
but oh that's just [ __ ] weird dad
kicked off Delta flight dear illiterate
[ __ ] there you go that's that's the
usual intro than I'm used to have you
seen the video of the guy and his family
getting kicked off a Delta Airlines
flight the other day the video is long
but worth watching and full at one point
they threatened to put him and his wife
in jail and his kids in foster care
what is going on my first question is
what the hell is going on the past week
with all these air airplane incidents
the Asian guy getting his ass kicked
yellow is brutal some young broads not
being allowed to board due to wearing
yoga pants and the world's largest
rabbit dying and transport under a plane
well I mean you know that can happen why
is this suddenly a trend secondly I have
to commend the father for his overall
attitude and demeanor in the video well
I while watching I couldn't help but
wonder how it all would have went down
if an angry East Coast father were in
this guy's shoes can you imagine an
angry father driving to the airport with
his [ __ ] wife and whining toddler
searching for parking getting the car
seat out of the car pushing a stroller
through security hauling your [ __ ] all
the way to the gate boarding and then
being told they sold your seat to
someone else and you either have to hold
your kid the entire flight or get off
the [ __ ] plane sounds more like an
episode of f is for family than it does
reality just wanted to share hope you
and the lovely Nia keep your DVR
relationship afloat in your flooded
house yeah I think it's time for other
passengers to speak up everybody just
sits there silently as they yank these
people off the plane I I don't
understand why like it's like yeah we
sold this to someone else it's like you
also sold it to me and I have my receipt
my ticket and I'm on this flight so
you're trying to say that someone else
is more importantly like I would do is I
would sue the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of that
airline they need to be sued because
it's their [ __ ] and they're making it
somebody else's they making it the
customers fault and the level of trauma
that they're bringing to people like
right now you know something why don't
we all just fire off angry [ __ ]
letters to United and Delta why don't we
get organized
why don't I mean if anybody can send me
the link where to do that you know the
problem is if they're all [ __ ] doing
it then where do you
you go to South West Southwest hasn't
done anything like that have they
American hasn't done it United's done it
dealt has done it so [ __ ] both of them
[ __ ] both of those airlines till they
learn how to treat people right and
Jesus Christ and they learn how to count
how many seats you got how many tickets
did you sell well there you go
know that you know man
the problem is that they're there an
organized entity and that the passengers
are not I remember that Flyers rights
thing was going down a while ago can
that thing be like revived and when they
start to yank somebody off with their
[ __ ] children I mean that's no one
wants that to happen to them that that
she said shouldn't that shouldn't I you
should be able to bully people like that
if you make a mistake as an airline you
should eat the cost instead of passing
it on to everybody else like tap
security go down there if they ever do
that to me I'm gonna be like I'm not
leaving I'm not leaving if you
physically remove me from my seat that I
paid for and I have the receipt I've
done nothing wrong I'm not a threat I'm
ready to fly I'm going to sue I'm gonna
summon I can't say the living [ __ ] I'm
going to sue you guys you know I mean up
today at least give them miles do they
do anything anymore
I don't know
corporations are they're a [ __ ]
disease they're completely out of
control and they have no the only thing
they have sympathy and empathy for is
the bottom line that's all they care
about and if you work in those worlds
like I understand it you're on the lower
levels you know you're not about that
but those upper levels you guys I don't
know I don't know how you do it but you
guys you're pieces of [ __ ]
that you could do that you know if I
[ __ ] if somehow that ever happened
one of my comedy shows there's no
[ __ ] way I'm letting that person get
kicked out there's no [ __ ] way
find a chair [ __ ] let the person sit
on the side of the stage this chairs on
the side of the stairs always you know
for the Union guys I'd give [ __ ] and get
one of those chairs in and to the person
let me sit on the side of this
take a picture you [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
up like that it's up to you they're
doing the exact opposite of what they
should be doing you know don't kick the
person up whoever you [ __ ] over you
give them whatever you have to give them
in the airport if they have some sort of
uh you know place they have to be you
got to figure out how to get them there
you know offer enough to people there's
going to be some single dude who's got
nothing to go home to other than a
[ __ ] futon just be like dude we'll
get you a 12-pack we'll give you thirty
thousand [ __ ] miles we wouldn't give
a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] multi-million
dollar there's a way to do it if I was
running an airline that way it would
just you know I'd have a guy come on
dressed like a [ __ ] game show host
all right and be like I got cash in my
suit pocket you know have a couple of
hot chicks dressed like bunnies you know
that'll [ __ ] walk it down you know or
if you gay you know you're gay dude I
know I have a couple of [ __ ] shredded
tanned up guys shirtless whatever the
[ __ ] you want
it'd be the greatest walk you ever had
up to [ __ ] tarmac you know give you a
stack of cash like [ __ ] Henry Hill
you know why don't you do it that way
instead of coming down [ __ ] all knees
and elbows and gorillas and some gorilla
somebody off a [ __ ] plane it's so
stupid
all right boyfriend troubles hey Bill I
was wondering if you could help with
issues I'm having with my boyfriend he's
really sweet but sometimes too sweet now
Jesus he's too submissive and I wish he
could be more dominant all right okay
he's [ __ ] he would give up his seat
is that what you're saying I don't know
how to bring it up to him without
hurting his feelings I really want to do
BDSM bondage sadomasochists with the
screen just went out rape roleplay but
every time we try it it never works
Oh how can i top off toughen him up oh
my god that's a [ __ ] sketch right
there he's too sweet he's a sweet nice
guy and you want to do that with a sweet
nice guy hey don't move or I'll lug I'll
pop you on your head how do you got to
speak a little more firmer than that
I will bop you on the head stop saying
pop you're drying me up um how can I
tough him up you know what you can't you
can't what you're looking to do you
can't do what the person like that you
just got to understand that he's a
square peg trying to fit into a round
hole they'll [ __ ] pun intended and uh
I don't know I you know it's like that
whole sex thing you got to like you guys
you got a vibe with each other if the
vibe isn't there especially with
something like that I mean that's gonna
be it's gonna be the most awkward thing
ever do you do the whole act out do you
tell him to go outside and try to like
you know he probably knocked on the door
hello here to rape you if that's okay
uh yeah yeah you're what I would say you
with the wrong guy that's all um so you
gotta you know I don't know I I don't I
have no idea I don't know what to tell
you um yeah I'm gonna leave it at that
I really need Nia here you know that's
just like a whole I don't know that you
can do that is there any woman out there
have you been able to because I got to
tell you from the other side when I want
to back in the day when I was a single
man you know
they'll pass you back for things you
know we remove um what I would do well I
guess you've already done this so it's
not working on it what I would always do
when you're trying to like get a woman
to not be so sick because it's really
with a lot of women they're super
self-conscious it's like they don't know
what they want to do I want to try it's
this so afraid of how a guy that they
actually like is going to judge them so
what I did was I would just gradually I
would just create this environment where
it's just like yeah I'm not going to I'm
not going to judge you I don't whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do and I really
believe that I mean just like I don't
judge anybody whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do if yet that's what you're
into go ahead and do it as long as the
other person is also went to it you know
that's fine so you had to create this
environment where they weren't afraid to
say what they wanted to try which I used
to say you were drawing out their inner
[ __ ] which is still judgmental you
really want what you don't is you
freedom up um you know it's like Frank
Gipp freaking freeze freeing up as a
comedian you know you just sort of leave
your act behind he just you know you
bomb a little bit then you get relaxed
then you find trying to free yourself up
on an instrument I imagine it's the same
way there's no difference same thing in
the bedroom however what the [ __ ] is
that noise is that my phone oh yes it is
oh Jesus Christ
anyways alright I get off the phone here
so um there are certain people they they
don't have like what you're what you're
looking for them this person probably
doesn't have an in them so I I don't
know what to tell you but I mean if you
haven't done anything else you kind of
started way down the [ __ ] Road you
know what I mean Jesus Christ just have
them slap your ass a little bit I mean
[ __ ] baby steps go rent what about
Bob learn about baby steps and maybe you
could gradually you know take this sweet
innocent person and turn them into a
[ __ ] deviant I have no idea I don't
know what
to tell you unfortunately Nia is still
sleeping downstairs so I don't know I
don't know what to tell you uh it's been
my experience that you know but if
someone's not into it they're not into
it you just [ __ ] leave it at that
right it's not what it is Jesus this is
awkward
alright that's the podcast that's the
podcast go Celtics how about the [ __ ]
predator first ones to advance to the
Conference Finals beating meet me in st.
Louie Louie blues go home cup las' once
again once again 50 [ __ ] years no cup
the Edmonton Oilers coming back after
that brutal [ __ ] loss in overtime um
Jesus is gonna be Edmonton and the
Predators there's gonna be the Ducks oh
god I don't I just never been I just
could never get over I've never forgiven
them for being owned by Disney and named
after a kids movie The Mighty Ducks you
know maybe if they still had the [ __ ]
intestinal fortitude as they always used
to say in wrestling to still call
themselves the Mighty Ducks the fact
that they got it they got rid of the
mighty you know it's like they're trying
to run from their history it's like KFC
your Kentucky Fried Chicken you know
stop trying to [ __ ] lighten it up um
wait a minute who the [ __ ] is left yeah
I still think the Penguins are going to
do it you know Crosby's comeback seems
to be all right
I think the Pens got it but I can say
that haven't watched 10 games this year
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check
in on you on on Thursday all right